es gibt ein bild was diese dramatischen
momente sehr eindrucksvoll man kann fast
sagen künstlerisch zeigt ein fotograf
dem ist das gelungen festzuhalten und
ich mag einmal erklären was genau wir
hier sehen hier in dieser ecke
das ist der gazastreifen und was wir
hier sehen das ist so eine raketen sei
verdi wird abgefeuert mitten in der
nacht und man kann das gut sehen diese
raketen werden mitten aus einem
wohngebiet abgefeuert das ist keine
armee stellung dass es keine
militärbasis das ist nicht irgendwo in
der wüste sondern zwischen wohnhäusern
zwischen schulen zwischen kindergärten
werden diese raketen abgefeuert warum
weil man natürlich weiß wenn die
israelische luftwaffe diese terror
stellung treffen will dann hat sie die
große herausforderung das drumherum
viele zivile ziele sind die man eben
unter gar keinen umständen treffen will
und das ist diese horror entscheidung
die israelische militärs gerade
minütlich treffen müssen hier drüben
diese aufsteigenden raketen das ist das
israelische abfang system das es iron
dome ein system über das in den
vergangenen tagen viel gesprochen wurde
denn diese raketen diese abwehrraketen
die retten leben die steigen auf es gibt
unterschiedliche systeme da drin sitzen
tatsächlich echte soldaten menschen die
feiern diese abwehrraketen ab und jede
einzelne dieser raketen probiert dann am
ende
feindliche raketen in der luft zu
zerstören und so zu verhindern dass
diese feindlichen raketen ins ziel
treffen können und am ende leben töten
knapp 2000 raketen hat die hamas etwa
abgefeuert abgefeuert rund 90 prozent
der raketen konnten abgefangen werden
ein sensationeller wert und man muss
sich nur vorstellen was eigentlich ohne
iron dome wäre wenn diese 2000 raketen
ins ziel gekommen werden wieviel
menschen wie viele kinder in israel in
diesen tagen gestorben wären es gibt
andere beeindruckende grafiken die noch
einmal den konflikt zeigen denn es gibt
ja immer so diesen narrativ ach naja die
hamas die schießt da ihre selbst
gebastelten kleinen raketen ab einen
wirklichen schaden können die ja gar
nicht ab anrichten
aber das ist schon lange nicht mehr so
die hamas wird ausgestattet aus dem
ausland die amas wird finanziert aus dem
iran und von dort kommen eben raketen
die das gesamte
mittlerweile treffen können wir haben es
gesehen tel aviv wurde beschossen aber
mittlerweile reicht eben dieses
raketenarsenal auch um aus dem
gazastreifen bis ganz nach oben nach
haifa zu feuern
das gesamte land kann aus gaza ins
visier genommen werden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren